das opfer musste wegen seiner schweren
kopfverletzungen in ein künstliches koma
versetzt haben sein gesundheitszustand
von der mediziner weiter in seiner
edition ist rita heute das ist ich
glaube das ist die schlimmste hilf mir
folgte ich jemals gesehen habe als
unsere lieblings ratgeber channel vor
einigen wochen ein video hochgeladen hat
wo es um einen nazi oder mehrere nazis
ging habe ich mir gedacht okay kleine
ausrutscher haben sollte man überhaupt
unterhaltungs videos über nazis machen
so kommt bestimmt nicht wieder vor
falsch gedacht hilf mir diese wunderbare
sendung hat tatsächlich noch eine folge
gemacht ich will es keine starren aber
es ist noch einmal auf das video heißt
nach sie bruder meine familie akzeptiert
man freundlich und leider habt ihr spaß
daran dass ich mir sowas anschaue ist
lasst uns einfach nochmal die
beschreibung lesen es ist einfach geil
jede folge von hilf mir junge leute
verzweifelt beschreibt ein problem wie
er der probleme
das sagt schon mal alles beschreibt ein
problem wie es im leben eines teenagers
passieren könnte lass mal kurz war durch
unseren kopf zirkulieren okay ein
problem die es im leben eines teenagers
passieren könnte der nazi wurde
sowas passiert möchte nämlich
berns leute ich habe mich wirklich dass
diese haus stellt auf einem kanal zu
sehen ist was ist das ohne wird diese
aussage diese erste zählen sie konnten
von dieser folge sind schon so ehren los
schlimm
selbst wenn ich jetzt darüber lustig
mache was ich machen werde es ist halt
immer noch
es ist mein erster gedanke des gerade
erst die leute die da sind sind ja
laienschauspieler also es sind in der
regel keine professionellen schauspieler
sondern leute die halt irgendwas über
ein gemeinsamer film agentur gesagt
haben ja ich höre rtl2 mitspielen jetzt
mal ganz ehrlich fragen die leute die in
dieser folge mitgespielt haben wieso
macht man sowas mit 2
ich kann mir sagt wie ich denke leute
und ich bin wieder in besonders linker
noch ein besonderes recht der menschen
relativ gemäßigt aber in dem moment wo
ich da ran komme und die hüfte sagen
dass ich selbst wird so für eine rolle
ist sowas sagen muss ganz ehrlich ich
würde lieber anlauf nehmen und zur
nächsten autobahn brücke rennen und
runterspringen als dass ich so etwas
sage
damit sich auch die klassiker der rechte
typ her übels sauer und der link ist
wirklich hätte das auch so und so kommt
der folgen die gegend als ein halbes
lächeln im gesicht nicht hat sich landes
erwartet hätte aber die systeme ist ja
mal wieder komplett beschlossen so ein
typ übels sauber wobei okay
wahrscheinlich ist es gibt dieses
standbild hier danach einig beide
klar der junge mann hier gerade eben
flüchtete vom tatort eines
gewaltverbrechens aber für den
gepflegten doppelten mittelfinger ist
mir zwar das war immer noch zeit
jaja dem geht es gut
ein bisschen cats sind 34 wir brauchen
dringend notarzt hier das ist hier auch
klassiker die polizisten die mit dem
handy telefonieren wenn sie gerade eine
meldung durch geben müssen man hört sich
in deutschland immer wieder es wird
deutlich gespart bei ausgaben nicht nur
fürs militär sondern auch für die
polizei die küsten leider alle
funkgeräte die sie hatten um sowas zu
klären verkaufen können jetzt nur noch
mit ihren eigenen handys telefonieren na
klar
bewusstlos ja aber es geht nicht darum
ob du noch atmung hast du den typen der
am boden liegt ja ja ja ich habe nur
noch schreiben
ja also die täter die die habe ich bei
einem bei einem casting irgendwo in köln
kennengelernt
der eine heißt markus der andere auf
ihre mode kommt sogar davon der übelsten
voll sprint verfolgung zurück denkt ihr
derart mit nur ein bisschen flacher
bisschen geld durchschnaufen
dieser mann hier ist deutschlands
zukunft im marathon sprintet gute 34
minuten durch kommt zurück noch kein
bisschen
haben sie eigentlich auch schon war
ziemlich nah dran könnte ja die täter
beschreiben hat die kommen die kenne ich
vom casting sowie wurden eingeladen zu
einem casting unter filmpool heißt die
firma aber so und ja gesagt
so habt ihr bock gegen sie zu spielen
die so ein bisschen die haben gesagt ja
machen wir keine pizza julia stecken
einer echten zwickmühle auf der einen
seite möchte sie natürlich ihre nur
nicht verraten das ist ihr gutes recht
ein zeugnisverweigerungsrecht bezüglich
ihres bruders okay okay der typ zum
bruder ok notiert abgehakt aber ich
frage mich wirklich gerade warum hat
nicht einfach jeder einzelperson die
dieser folge mitwirken sollte einfach
gesagt nein
besonders mache ich mit dass es zu wenig
halt nicht kommt es schon für mich
verarscht das ok und das ist für mich
schon schwer das zu verraten so schlimm
ist das aber die spiele damit machen den
experten machen denn sie machen die nazi
schwester und ich bin gespannt wie sie
aus der zwickmühle herauskommt lügen
jedenfalls dafür ja nicht eine stunde
später nach ihrer befragung auf der
wache ist julia immer das ist jetzt mal
den ton los um hatte jetzt
unwahrscheinlich sind da die funkgeräte
in die polizei hat die funkgeräte nicht
mehr dafür jetzt der sprecher von heat -
punkt gerät und funk durch funkgerät ans
mikrophon ab am ende des raumes und die
maximal beschissene song qualität
sicherzustellen schon besucht ihren fans
ja ist so sicher habe ich in der form
jetzt andere nicht gehört er trifft
irgendwann freuen oder gefallen denn
ewiger alles klar weil dirigiert hier
hat man mich jetzt echt nicht gut solche
punkte stress ist das sicher bist du
sicher dass du nicht gut geht weil ich
kann glaube ich das jetzt besser
beurteilen bist du sicher dass du nicht
gut geht ja bin ich
ich merke gerade wenn du magst wir
können auch einen anderen tag etwas
trinken gehen
also ich will euch nicht sagen wir und
beziehungen zu nehmen haben aber so nah
ziel der familie ist eine sache die
sollte man ansprechen denn früher oder
später kommt raus dass spätestens wenn
er sie zu hause besucht am zimmer des
bruders vorbeiläuft
das ein oder andere symbole passiert
nicht mehr beschreiben möchte da hängt
sollte man schon ansprechen ist aus
davos sage dass mein bruder nazi
schläger ist der heute fast ein
ausländer tot geprügelt hat und genau
das ist der punkt wo man einfach
abbrechen sollte spätestens wenn mal den
satz gesagt hat man ist beim dreh für
diese hilfen der folge sollte es klick
macht im kopf wo man sollte sagen ich
bin raus also ich weiß nicht was sie
damit den schauspielern machen die nie
drogen endet sie nicht checken was da
abgeht aber das kann doch kein normaler
mensch sagen und sich da denken also
komisch findet gesetzt nicht ist ja ganz
normal zur selben zeit
julias bruder eric ist auf krawall
gebürstet und klappt bei dem läuft aber
auch immer was verkehrt oder die leute
ziemliche gegend julias bruder eric ist
auf krawall gebürstet ganz klassischer
fall von nackenmuskeln verkürzung
kombiniert mit rasierklingen unter den
armen führt in der regel dazu dass leute
noch so durch die gegend laufen oder
weiß auch so ist eine ernst zu nehmende
medizinische konditionen mitleid geht an
der stelle nicht raus und dem
asylbewerber auf frischer tat erwischt
die handtasche geklaut versteht ja also
verstehe ich schon gesteht doch was bei
uns etwa 45 jähriger auf offener straße
schwer verprügelt die polizei hat
zurzeit keine hinweise auf die täter
will ein fremdenfeindliches motiv aber
nicht ausschließen
ich weigere mich zu denken dass ein
mensch der bei klarem verstand ist so
eine rolle spielt glaube ich nicht aber
das ist mir dann die mit dem gemacht
oder kann dir da druck gesetzt wer weiß
vielleicht steht hinter der kamera vom
typ mit gezogener waffe so dass dem
motto du sagst hast du ja nicht weg das
opfer mussten wie seiner schweren
kopfverletzungen in ein künstliches koma
versetzt seinen gesundheitszustand
wie sieht sie noch weiter inside.de
stunden
rita heute das ist ich glaube das ist
die schlimmste hilfen gefolge die ich
jemals gesehen habe
wisst ihr was leute ganz ehrlich ich bin
jetzt an einem punkt angekommen ich
werde mir diese polit zum ersten mal
seit monaten nicht zu ende anschauen
das geht einfach nicht ich frage mich
ernsthaft wie so was im fernsehen laufen
kann wirklich wie die leute bei so etwas
mitmachen können reinen gewissens wird
ich will ehrlich gesagt gar nicht mehr
so viel mit dieser folge zu tun haben
auch wenn ich die kommentare schon so
richtig so richtung politische
diskussion das ist nicht mein ding hier
auf youtube ist aber auch dass man
vollkommen unabhängig davon wie man so
politisch denkt mit ein bisschen
menschenverstand merkt egal ob ich jetzt
da steht da oder mich gar nicht stehe
ich noch besoffen der glied soll umgang
das ist nicht so cool aber ich habe
trotzdem wie man feuchte drüben
eigentlich vorgeschlagen das video
verlinkt tut mir leid dass ich in dieser
folge auf einem kanal gesehen hat das
war wirklich die schlechteste hilf mir
folge er war